I'd like to open with a quote.
I read a book the other day, about speaking
in public, and it said something about opening
with a quote.
Okay.
It wasn't
actually a book.
It was a web page.
It was called...
Top ten things you should
never do while giving a talk.
But I'm going to open with a quote anyway.
Because this is where it all started.
We are about to study the idea of a
computational process.
Computational processes are abstract beings
that
inhabit computers.
As they evolve, processes manipulate other
abstract things,
called data.
The evolution of a process is directed by
a pattern of rules
called a program.
People create programs to direct processes.
In effect, we
conjure the spirits of the computer with our
spells.
So when I first read
that, two years ago, it was like something
that had been misaligned suddenly
snapped into place.
This idea that the code that we write, the
artifact that we're creating, and
the process that unfurls in the system as
that is being evaluated are two
separate things.
This is so simple.
It's such a fundamental idea.
But it's so
easy to overlook.
If our code is directing the evolution of
a process, then in
many ways it's a lot like the DNA in a cell,
directing the evolution of that
cell.
But DNA is really the most boring part of
the cell.
It just sits there,
curled up into little balls, being read, right?
And all around it, there's
this fantastic machinery that's involved in
finding pieces of the DNA in a
massively parallel way and unwrapping it and
parsing it and opening it up and
copying pieces out of it into RNA, jotting
it down, and RNA goes into the rest
of the cell and causes effects.
Some of it gets pulled into ribosomes, which
are these amazing molecular machines that
kind of ratchet in a little bit of
RNA and poop out a little bit of amino acid
at the top, and they find the
right amino acids to match that sequence of
codons in the RNA and then they
make this protein, which is like a data structure,
that has active sites.
It's
like an object in JavaScript.
And it causes effects on other things.
And we
can keep pushing this biological metaphor.
But the point is that there's a
party going on in there, and we weren't invited.
I want to go to that party.
So this talk is a series of three steps.
Of me
trying to find a path.
To understand what's happening in this process,
as it's
evolving.
Step one is data.
Our data structures in JavaScript are becoming
increasingly sophisticated.
This is in response to our applications that
we're
developing, becoming increasingly sophisticated,
and there's a lot of
information added in asynchronous processes.
And when we share mutable state
and asynchronous processes we have exactly
the same problem that people in
other communities have when they share mutable
state between threads in a
multi-threading environment.
So now we've got things here, thing A, and
some
other piece of code over here, thing B, and
these two things are communicating
through a communication channel.
Sharing messages back and forth.
But if
they're also sharing mutable state, they're
communicating through that too.
And that communication happens instantly and
it bypasses the communication
passageways of your application.
So that means you have this spooky action
at a distance going on, when you're
dealing with mutable state.
Right?
And it's...
All right.
So...
We have
persistent data structures that help us have
immutable data so we can reason
about our processes and our programs in a
more effective fashion.
And they do
that in a performant way, rather than having
to deep copy everything like you
would if you were making immutable data yourself.
So we're looking at two of
those, immutable JS and Mori, from a particular
perspective.
So you have to
know a little bit about (inaudible) trees.
Or tris.
Who says try?
Who says
tree?
Either way is fine.
You're both right.
As long as people understand what
you're saying.
I'll try to say tri, because it disambiguates
better.
But a
tri is a tree.
This is just a super high level surface topology
of a
(inaudible).
They're really interesting data structures.
We put all of our
values down at the bottom and use pieces of
the key to walk down to that
value.
We're going to hash those keys first, so we
can pull an unlimited
number of bytes out of them.
If we hit the end of the hash we rehash.
So it
gives us consistent and unlimited hash lengths,
so we can deal with conflicts.
Because if two things have the same key or
the same piece of the hash of the
key, then we have to go to the next piece
of the hash.
So we're going to take
pieces of the hash, five bits at a time, and
use that to walk down the street.
Those five bits give us 32 possible values.
So we're going to have an array of
32 possible values, up to 32 values, as the
child of a particular node.
And
that's going to dereference into its children.
So the things you have to remember from that
are: 32 and hashing.
Hashing
gives us good distribution properties.
We would rather have shallow, wide
trees.
We don't want deep trees, because depth increases
our space usage and
also our time usage.
So we're going to put these two libraries
under a
microscope.
We're going to use a thing called underscore,
which is kind of
like a data structure oscilloscope or something.
And this is slightly the
wrong aspect ratio.
So you're not seeing all of the slides.
That just says...
Full history of the data structure down there.
Okay.
So these are the joys of AV confusion.
Which was...
Yeah, my fault, not
theirs.
They did an excellent job of recovering from
that.
So we're going to
write out our data structure as a single long
list.
Right?
We're going to take
all of the numbers in it, and for each number
in it, we're going to generate a
pixel.
That pixel will be colored according to that
number.
We're going to
take that line of pixels, turn it on its side
and make a column, and every
time we make a new version of this data structure,
we're going to move
everything over and put the new column in
place, so we can see the history of
it.
So let's cross our fingers and see if we can
see what that looks like.
Here we
are...
Oh, man.
Aspect ratios!
All right.
So everything is kind of up in this
corner.
But that's cool.
We can zoom here.
This is the power of zoom.
All
right.
So what we've done here is to start putting
in some numbers.
We see
this triangle shape.
That's what we're expecting.
Because every single tick,
we're adding a new number, enqueuing a new
number.
We see random numbers here.
Those correlate to the numbers that we've
added.
So it just stays in place in
this queue.
The secondary feature we can pick out here
is these shaded areas,
which are shaded...
They're less light, because they are down
an extra level.
So the lightness is corresponding to our depth
in the tree.
This area is down
an extra level, so we can see it fills up
with 32 things.
And then those get
added to the main data structure.
And we start a new nursery at that point.
Everybody on board so far?
So both
of these -- and I've cleverly code named them
blue and red -- because this is
not a performance comparison between Mori
and immutable JS.
It's just -- we're
going to use these as a way of understanding
what's happening in the process
and in the program by looking at the data.
Additionally, even if you figure
out which is which, which is not very hard,
after I hit a couple more buttons
-- I'm using older versions of them.
So it's not an effective performance
comparison.
So we start taking numbers off.
They look more or less the same,
but suddenly we see a really big difference.
Here in the blue zone, we have a
data structure that is the same size.
Right?
Here it was growing and here it's
the same size every tick.
And what we're doing every single tick is
pushing on
a number and dequeuing a number off of this
end.
And we can see it's actually
happening in the data structure.
Right?
There's a couple of strange little
places in here, like this little blip here,
that occurs about six ticks in.
I
have no idea why but it's there every single
time -- I haven't looked at the
code for either of these.
The point is to understand it by looking at
the
pictures.
So this is a traditional queue, other than
the fact that we still have our
nurseries going.
Shifting off of one end and pushing onto the
other end.
There's probably some performance implications
here, because shift or unshift,
whichever one we use, in JavaScript is not
a very fast function.
Over here
we're doing something completely different.
In particular, we can see that a
whole new triangle has emerged, and we're
keeping the old data up here.
So
what we infer from this is that rather than
destroying things as we dequeue
them, we're keeping pointers.
And in fact, we can see these pointers here
in
this middle section.
We're keeping pointers into this data and
we're floating
a counter to the end of it.
As we dequeue things.
And then when we hit the end of the old kind
of master section or new growth
section, we're dropping everything.
And this new growth section down here
becomes a new old one, and it starts getting
dequeued, and we start over again
here.
Does that kind of make sense so far?
So what we understand at this point
is that there's a massive difference between
these two libraries and how they
handle queues.
In particular, there may be some performance
implications for
that difference.
We understand this not by looking at the code,
but just by
looking at these pictures.
Let me show you another example.
We're going to
start throwing random numbers in here.
So we'll take a number and we'll give
it a key that is the number with the letter
pre-pended, and insert this into
the map.
So what do we immediately see when we're looking
at this?
We
immediately see that this blue side is about
twice as tall as the red side
over here.
And so we can start to think that maybe there's
some spatial implications
here.
Right?
That our space usage is a little bit stronger
over here.
Let's
turn on another way of looking at this.
So this is a flattened tree view.
What
we're going to do is take our tree with all
of its levels, and we're going to
flatten every single level.
And then we're going to turn the whole thing
on
its side.
So if we look over here, we can see that we
have our initial node
here, this blue is a pointer to the secondary
node here, this points to an
array of 32 pointers, each point to a dereference
column here, and then those
point to this array over here, and so on.
But just from eyeballing this...
I don't know how much of this you can
actually see...
We can see that these are adding new key value
pairs in very
different ways.
This one is a lot more compact.
So this reconfirms our
intuition that we saw just from looking at
the sizes.
Let's try, instead of
adding these randomly, adding them...
Hang on.
Come on.
You can do it.
All
right.
Apparently the reload button is not actually
the reload button.
Borrowed laptop issues.
All right.
What's happening here?
Now we're loading in
numbers sequentially, instead of randomly.
And something that we started to
see toward the end of this one becomes very
clear.
We're seeing this banding effect.
Whereas these colors are well distributed,
these colors are patterned in a very particular
way.
And what that's telling
us -- if we look here, we can see the same
story.
This one, even though we're
adding them sequentially, is well populated.
It's fairly dense.
Over here, we
see something that has these increasing sort
of harmonic oscillations that are
going on in the number of collisions.
So this tells us that the hashing
algorithm that blue is using is not distributing
values or keys as well as the
hashing algorithm that red is using.
In fact, we're getting very bad hashing
behavior out of this.
It's probably modulo or something like that.
Oh, dear.
Fortunately, that was actually the end of
the conclusions that we were going
to draw from that.
So what we've learned so far is that you should
always
bring a backup laptop when you're giving a
talk.
And the second thing that
we've learned is that we can make observations
about a piece of code without
ever looking at that code at all.
So we've learned something about these two
libraries.
But we didn't have to look at any code.
And that's important,
because it doesn't matter how good or poorly
written that code was.
Right?
It
could be obfuscated.
Both of these are well written libraries.
But it doesn't
matter.
For example, if a library is the framework
we're using or that someone
else is using, we have to take over maintenance
of that code, there's hundreds
of thousands of lines in the framework, so
we could read the entire thing to
understand how it works, or we could try to
go in the back door and try to
develop our intuitions by actually observing
the process unfolding.
So one
problem that we saw...
Or I guess we didn't see, but we should have
seen --
was that there was limited screen real estate.
We had the opposite problem.
There was way too much screen real estate.
So fitting everything in can be an
issue.
Sorry?
Will that actually work with images?
It works!
That's so great.
Thank
you!
Cool.
So we have some issues with the amount of
available space to us.
So
we could, for example, look at a single line
of code, and observe this line of
code, or we could observe the entire code
base.
Right?
And watch the entire
process unfolding.
So we can kind of pick a place along this
continuum that
we're interested in.
We could also, on the temporal dimension,
look at a
single operation at a time.
Or we could look at the entire process unfolding
in realtime.
And so we have really good tools for this
end of the spectrum.
For looking at a single operation, one at
a time.
Right?
Step-through
debuggers work great for this.
And they give us a street level view of what's
happening.
Right?
We're taking -- we're walking through the
town of our process.
But they
don't give us the 10,000-foot view of what's
happening all at once, so we can
develop our intuitions about it, and we don't
have very good tools for that
right now.
So that's what's on the left hand of the slide.
On the right hand
is some mathematics that ostensibly proves
that the information we have is
greater than the information we would like
to have, but really it's a ham
handed way of trying to work the '80s theme
into my presentation.
All right.
So...
What we're going to do...
Because JavaScript is huge -- the ES5 spec
is
over 250 pages, and because we write huge
applications in it, we're going to
punt a little on this problem and we're going
to start with a system where we
can see everything at full granularity, with
the entire process, all at the
same time.
Okay?
So that means we're going to have to design
a language.
We
have some design constraints for this.
We're going to keep it very simple, so
we have an 8-bit architecture.
Our memory is going to be 256 bytes.
And we
would like to introduce random programs, because
the whole idea is to gain
intuition about the process that's unfolding
from a program without actually
understanding the program.
If we understand the program, then we don't
need to
do that.
Right?
So we need random programs.
So that means we're going to fuzz the compiler.
We
would like there not to be any compile time
errors when we do this.
We would
like there not to be any runtime errors.
And I will throw in an additional
constraint that we want all of our programs
to terminate.
This sounds easy,
right?
Sure.
Oh my gosh.
It's so tiny.
Woo!
All right.
So here is a program in
our language, and this, over on the right,
is supposed to be the JSConf
Pegasus, but...
My pixel art skills are not very good.
It looks more like a
flying aardvark with a Tommy gun or something.
(laughter)
>> All right.
So if we run this, we can see that it's some
type of
image-blurring program.
And just so you know that...
Really?
Okay.
Did I get
bounced off the subnet?
Is that why I can't refresh?
Agh!
Thank you.
Okay.
So...
I was going to show you that we could edit
the program and it would
still work.
You'll have to take my word for that.
That's the magic of live
demos.
So that's great.
But we're not seeing individual steps.
So we want to
go back and be able to actually see things
at a granular level.
So now we can
see the stack, we can see the return stack.
These are the two...
This is the
entire process unfolding.
We see the memory.
We see the code.
We see where
we're at in the code, thanks to this highlight.
And we see the full variable
structure right here.
So this is everything.
If we took a picture of this, we
could replicate this process at this moment
perfectly, and we could step
through and see that it is in fact doing some
things as we step through.
But
in zooming into this level, we've lost our
ability to see things unfold in
realtime.
So now we're back to the step-through debugger
zone.
So what we can do is...
We have a connection between code, which,
when it gets
compiled down, all of these codes over here
-- or these commands over here --
get pushed down into numbers.
So we can actually make an array of numbers
out
of our code.
And that's exactly what happens.
It gets compiled down to a
machine code, which is an array of bytes.
So at the machine code level, we
have an array of bytes, and our memory is
an array of bytes.
We have a sort of
trivial form of homoiconicity, where your
code and your data is the same
thing.
It's the same type of data structure as you
typically operate on.
Machine code always has a trivial form of
homoiconicity, but in our case, we
have a similar trick up our sleeves, which
is that our memory is being mapped
to an image, so there's an isomorphism between
the memory structure and the
image, and there's also an isomorphism between
the code and an image, or icon.
So maybe our homoiconicity is not so trivial
after all.
That was a really
involved joke.
All right.
So we can look at this as an image instead.
Which is where things
start to get fun.
So this is our program running...
Again, we could take a
snapshot and reform our entire process at
a moment in time.
You can see the
read head is this kind of white square here
that's jumping through this
subroutine.
And you can see that it is in fact performing
this image blur on
our memory.
So...
That's great.
But what we're really interested in is random
programs.
And I can't reload this, and it's stuck in
a really silly loop.
Are
we good?
Oh, yes.
Nice.
Okay.
So we're watching an entirely random program.
All the colored spots correlate to different
kinds of op codes.
This is an
exit, so it's the beginning of the subroutine,
and this is a jump, so it's
jumping to the next subroutine when it hits
that.
The grey areas correlate to numbers that serve
as constants in our program,
and what can we infer about this?
It's actually hard to infer much of anything
from this system.
We can see that this square is blinking a
lot, and that
we're going to take a little while before
we end, because we've got 200
counting down on a return stack.
So what we're doing here is...
We're applying
the program to itself.
We put a copy of it in memory, and we have
it modify
itself.
And then when it's done, when it terminates,
we're going to take the
modified version and run that against itself.
And we're going to keep doing
this until our program doesn't do anything
interesting.
Well, this one is
certainly doing something interesting -- down
here, at least.
Or we find a cycle where program A, applied
to A, gives us program B, which,
when applied to B, gives us program A again.
And then we will be very happy
and have champagne or something.
All right.
So...
This was a nice experiment.
But it's a little hard to infer much about
these programs, because the
language is a little obscure.
And because we haven't looked at these pictures
long enough.
What if we could do this with JavaScript?
That's the $25,000
question.
So what if we could look at the interpreter
for this in JavaScript?
So I was hoping to not have to do this.
But I have to do this.
So we'll take
this over here.
And we will do this and we will do this.
Oh, good.
Okay.
All
right.
Everyone cross your fingers.
Take a deep breath.
And we'll see if we
can make this work.
All right.
So what we'd like to see is our virtual machine
for this little language that we've written,
running in realtime, in
JavaScript.
And over on the left, that's exactly what
we're seeing.
So we're
back to the step-through on the right.
We're stepping through, one step at a
time.
But as we step through, we're seeing three
columns over here, which
correlate to three files.
This is the core virtual machine.
This is the
renderer.
And this is the index HTML.
Can you see that?
Can anyone see that at
all?
You can?
It's visible?
Okay.
Cool.
So as we step through, there's going
to be lots of flashing colors here.
We can see different parts of this program
being evaluated.
So this is the actual underlying virtual machine.
This, for example, is the
draw function.
And it's longer than you would expect, and
it's also very, very
hot.
So this is forming a heat map.
Because there's a tiny little virtual DOM
inside here.
So I just call it 256 times a tick.
But the point of this isn't
to be a profiler.
Right?
We already have really good profilers for
finding hot
spots in our code.
The point of this is to -- at a 10,000-foot
view --
understand the process that's unfolding from
our code.
And...
So another
interesting thing that we can do is not just
watch this in realtime, which we
can do a little more effectively if we speed
this up -- we can also slow it
down and watch it happening essentially a
tick at a time.
So we can see the
process...
We can see the underlying engine kind of flowing
through.
And
unfortunately this code is not very interesting.
Because it's calling the draw
function 256 times.
But we can rewind and try to...
We can rewind...
Maybe we can rewind.
We can't rewind.
(laughter)
>> Uh...
Really?
Okay.
So this isn't very interesting for me, this
particular
piece of code, because I wrote it.
So I understand exactly what's happening
here.
If we look at something else, though, something
bigger, like, for
example, a framework of some kind that we're
not familiar with -- this one is
Agility JS.
And then if we do this magical thing that
may or may not work...
Okay, good.
So I'm using fondue under the hood, which
is an instrumentation
library
written for Theseus, which is a debugger for
brackets.
Typing and
talking simultaneously are surprisingly difficult
things to do well.
Okay.
Flashy lights!
Woo.
All right.
So what are we really looking at here?
What we're seeing unfold before us is...
The entire process that's inside of
Agility JS, as it's handling the things that
we clicked over here -- so if we
click this, for example --
and then we...
No.
Okay.
So I should slow this down
a little.
Okay.
So we can observe at a high level the functions
that are being
called and the flow of functions as they're
being called.
So this shows us
something about the process.
And we can draw some inference from it.
But there's more that we need.
What
we'd really like to see is the data that's
flowing through here as well.
And
we'd like those data flow pathways to be highlighted.
We want to be able to
sort of pour data in some input of our program,
and watch as it trickles
through the function calls and invocations,
and watch it as it pools up in
some place and stays there for a while.
See how it interfaces with other data
that's flowing through.
We want to be able to understand the applications
that
we're working with at the level of the process
that they're evolving.
And we
want this because reading code is very slow,
and it requires that we have an
interpreter in our head.
And if we can do this effectively, then we
can understand -- for example,
frameworks that we've never used -- at an
intuitive level, without ever
actually having used them or read their code
or their documentation.
So I want
this for the programs that I'm writing, and
I also want it for the programs
that I'm reading.
And if you want it too, then I think we should
work together
on this.
I think we should make this happen.
I think we should get this -- not
this, but something like this -- into dev
tools.
So we have it available for
everything that we're doing.
Let's augment our vision.
Let's let the computer
do the hard work of helping us understand
what it is we're working with.
Let's
go to that party.
Thank you.